gotta go to [ __ ] Coachella I don't
like when everyone has to go do the same
[ __ ] that everyone else I go further
from Coachella when that [ __ ] happens
I'm in New York your band goes on your
[ __ ] band you like goes on in a field
and you got to be out with all the
[ __ ] other humans your cows do that
you can do that absolutely you can be in
a field and watch music with a bunch of
other people like that but you have to
admit you're a cow if you do that you
are a cow it's too it's too hot it's too
hot there so if you go and it's that hot
somewhere there must be boa constrictor
so therefore watch out when you're in
Coachella watch out for the boa
constrictors because they're definitely
there because it's that hot no watch out
for lions because it's in Africa
obviously because it's that hot watch
out for Tigers because it's in Africa
out for snakes because it's in Africa
because it's obviously that hot watch
out for ostriches because it's in Africa
out for leopards because it's enough for
you because it's obviously that hot
watch out for Jaguar stop posin stop
going because other people are going and
I don't even give a [ __ ] if you really
like music if you really like music get
the [ __ ] iTunes [ __ ] Burning Man
[ __ ] Coachella [ __ ] all these [ __ ]
places where everyone goes and everyone
wears the hats and the [ __ ] scarves
each try to outscore of each other
Coachella is an [ __ ] place and
anything like that is it's an [ __ ]
place with guys with loose tank tops and
[ __ ] short shorts I'll [ __ ] on them
cows you go to [ __ ] Coachella and you
wear those long you wear long boots you
wear long boots and you're a cow at
[ __ ] Coachella and you got phrase on
you got fray all I wouldn't you know
what next year I'm gonna go to Coachella
I'm gonna go to Coachella and I'm gonna
[ __ ] yank all the long boots all
everybody I'm gonna buy expensive ticket
I'm gonna yank long boots off girls all
the girls are gonna be walking around
with no [ __ ] shoes or boots on I'm
gonna clip all the fray from the jeans
I'm gonna clip them all [ __ ] all of them
then when everyone is like no crystally
is cutting the [ __ ] phrase of
everyone taking all the boots I'm gonna
[ __ ] say it was a hologram okay
and and and that it was part of the
[ __ ] ticket and you paid for that
[ __ ] you paid to [ __ ] have your boots
taken and your phrase cut off because
the hologram did it [ __ ] game of
throwing boots [ __ ] your game of throne
boots [ __ ] your loose tank tops [ __ ]
your knee on sunglasses and hats that go
like this
got a new I got a new [ __ ] what is it
called a festival it's in my it's in my
[ __ ] it's nice and warm and it sucks
what's going everyone's going
everyone's getting a ticket VIP [ __ ] on
the wrists in my [ __ ] the killers are
playing it's gonna be [ __ ] phenomenal
and then they're still gonna be shitty
people that brag about the [ __ ] VIP
[ __ ] they're gonna be like yeah we
didn't go through his [ __ ] we took
the VIP way we went through his dick
hole then we sat with the killers
festival in my body in my [ __ ] body
and now all your friends are going bring
your long boats and your neon sunglasses
in your hats
[ __ ] [ __ ] I've seen so many so many
snapchats of people in the backseat of
cars cramped together going to [ __ ]
Coachella I hope you're miserable in the
[ __ ] backseat it's cramped and I hope
your [ __ ] shins hurt I hope it's
digging into the backseat [ __ ]
air-conditioning and I hope it hurts
when you're watching [ __ ] the Zac
Brown Band over the phone I hope [ __ ]
Sparklehorse plays for for 12 hours and
I hope you sit there and watch it I hope
you sit and watch Sparklehorse for
[ __ ] 12 hours overnight and I hope
that you do that and you secretly don't
get the music but you pretend you do and
you still stay there and then you're
confused in life because of that and
that becomes who you are in your life
you know you start saying [ __ ] that your
life stuff even though you don't know
you do just because it's cool to like it
and then you have kids [ __ ] kids and
then your kids grow up and they get all
[ __ ] they're all shitty they go to
Coachella - no they don't go to go they
go to my body festival they're in my
[ __ ] dancin they're dancin it's in
the 20 years and Sparklehorse is playing
a reunion in my [ __ ] and your kids
went through my dick hole to get there
that's what it is and guess what they
don't [ __ ] get it either
in 20 years they don't get it either in
my [ __ ] but they're there
and they pretend to because that's what
you did they learned it from watching
you they learned it from watching you
just know if next year you see me
walking down the street with a scarf
coming out of my [ __ ] that that
belongs to someone who bought a ticket